JOE CORKERY: I'm
Joe Corkery, and I
lead the Healthcare and
Life Sciences product
team at Google Cloud.
When we first started
planning for Next,
we intended for this talk
to be about how health care
organizations are transforming
their businesses using
AI and ML.
However, since that
time, the world--
and especially as it
relates to health care--
has seen a completely different
type of transformation
as a result of COVID-19.
With that in mind, we decided
to focus this talk more
about how Google Cloud is
helping organizations respond
to COVID-19,
leveraging AI and ML,
Google Cloud's Healthcare
and Life Sciences products,
as well as some of the work
that our partners are doing.
I want to start by talking
through Google Cloud
Healthcare and Life Sciences
team's mission, which
is to create solutions to
empower provider, payer,
and pharma organizations
to transform their business
and the delivery of health care.
Our development efforts
to deliver on that mission
are primarily organized
around four main pillars.
Organize-- we want to make
it easy to ingest, normalize,
and join data to unlock
the potential of your data.
Accessible-- we want to
support open standards, APIs,
interoperability and discovery,
to ensure that the data can
be made accessible for use.
Secure-- we lead the industry
in security, privacy,
and compliance, from
endpoint to data center.
Everything we do here
is core to our mission
and at the heart of our work.
Useful-- with
secure, accessible,
and well-organized data, we aim
to help organizations generate
insights and new capabilities
that advance the Quadruple
Aim of health care.
The Quadruple Aim of
health care is a framework
of goals designed to improve
the patient experience of care,
improve the health
of populations,
reduce the per capita
cost of health care,
and improve the work experience
of clinicians and staff.
This useful pillar is
especially critical today
during the COVID19
pandemic, as organizations
seek to understand and take
action on a wide range of data
available to them.
Here's our overall
agenda for the session,
which we've divided into
three distinct parts.
In the first session, we will
cover the application of AI
to COVID forecasting,
and we'll be
joined by Dr. Thomas Tsai,
a surgeon and health policy
researcher in the
Department of Surgery
at Brigham and Women's Hospital
and in the Department of Health
Policy and Management at
the Harvard T.H. Chan School
of Public Health.
He's affiliated with the
Harvard Global Health Institute,
with whom Google
Cloud is partnered
on the development of the
COVID-19 public forecasts.
In the second session,
we'll dive a bit deeper
into how Google Cloud's
health care-specific product
offerings are being used
to address COVID-19.
Finally, in our
last session, we'll
highlight work being done
by one of our partners,
Schrodinger, and how it's
being used to combat COVID-19.
Let's get started.
Now I'd like to welcome
Dr. Thomas Tsai to share
his thoughts on our
collaboration to deliver
the COVID-19 public forecasts.
THOMAS TSAI: Thank you,
Joe, for that introduction.
As Joe said, my
name is Tom Tsai.
I'm a surgeon and assistant
professor in health policy
and management at the Harvard
School of Public Health
and a faculty member of
the Harvard Global Health
Institute.
The goal of the Harvard
Global Health Institute
is to provide actionable
data to guide policymaking
to improve health
in both the United
States and the global context.
During COVID-19, our efforts
have focused around three core
areas--
developing models of
US hospital capacity
to help plan for
storage capacity
to meet the demand of
COVID-19 cases, supporting
federal and state policymakers
in developing, testing targets,
and a contact tracing
strategy, and, three,
providing scientific
communication
to combat misinformation.
We are public health
researchers, health policy
experts and clinicians.
We try to bring all those
perspectives to bear
when informing policy response
to urgent health care needs,
such as the COVID-19 pandemic.
Over the last few
months, we have
embarked on a national
conversation in conjunction
with the Harvard Safra
Center for Ethics
and multiple academic groups,
think tanks, foundations,
and policy groups to
create convergence
around a key set of metrics
for suppression of COVID-19.
This has resulted in our
COVID-19 risk level dashboard
and test target dashboard,
globalepidemics.org.
Our goal has been to not just
show the underlying risk,
but more importantly
tie the community level
risk to a corresponding
set of public health
actions around testing
and non-pharmacological
interventions, such as social
distancing and even shutdowns.
While the dashboard
shows us where we are,
what it doesn't do is predict
what will happen in the future.
And because of this,
states and even counties
are unable to fully prepare
for what is to come.
If hospitals policymakers,
and public health officials
could predict with more
reliability future COVID-19 19
outbreaks, then they
could be better prepared.
This is where artificial
intelligence and machine
learning come into play.
Through AI and
machine learning, we
can create forecast
models that are
able to predict cases, deaths,
and other important metrics
over the next 14 days, at both
the US state and county level.
And this is where
Google Cloud comes in.
Cloud AI, in partnership with
the Harvard Global Health
Institute, has developed a
novel COVID-19 forecasting
model that is able to
predict cases, deaths,
and other important metrics
such as hospitalizations
in the 14-day period at the
US state and county level.
These forecasts are
powered by machine
learning informed
epidemiological models that
continuously learn from
underlying public data sets.
The forecasts are available
free to the public.
To generate the COVID-19
public forecasts,
Google Cloud researchers
developed a novel time series
machine learning
approach that combines
artificial intelligence with
a robust epidemiological
foundation.
By design, this new model
is trained on public data
and leverages an architecture
that allows researchers
to dive into the
different relationships
that the model has learned
to better interpret
why it makes certain forecasts.
One of the challenges of a
novel pandemic like COVID-19
is that traditional
epidemiological modeling
depends on assumptions
of certain parameters,
such as the transmission
rate, the incubation period,
and the risk of mortality.
What the AI machine
learning approach enables
is an opportunity to learn
from the data in real time
as you're progressing
through this pandemic.
We hope that these
measures not only
help the public understand
how the model works, but more
importantly, can enable
further innovations
in infectious disease modeling.
We're calling on
public health officials
to prioritize data
quality and transparency,
as these underlying data are
what informs and enables the AI
models to make accurate
predictions of health care
professionals.
As these data are
public, we hope
users will use
this data to create
their own dashboards
to guide and inform
local decision making.
There's a saying that
all models are wrong,
but some models are useful.
The COVID-19 public forecast
model is uniquely positioned
to provide not just
useful information,
but more importantly,
actionable insights
that can be used to help
suppress the COVID-19 pandemic.
It's been our privilege at the
Harvard Global Health Institute
to partner with Google Cloud
on this very important effort.
We look forward to continue
this ongoing collaboration.
JOE CORKERY: Thank, you Thomas.
I really appreciate you
participating in this session.
The COVID-19 public
forecast model
generates a 14-day forecast
of the development of COVID-19
in each US state and county.
It's intended to be used
as one of many signals
to help first responders in
health care, the public sector,
and other impacted organizations
to be better prepared for what
lies ahead.
The data is available
in BigQuery,
where users can interact with
it directly and without cost,
as it is included in the
COVID-19 public data set
program that makes a large
number of COVID-related data
sets freely searchable
on BigQuery.
the data can also be
downloaded directly as a CSV
for your own analysis
and your own tools.
Finally, we also created a
high level dashboard view
of the data using Google
Data Studio, which
is what you're seeing here.
Let's take a closer
look at that dashboard
now to get a better
understanding of the results.
In the COVID-19 public
forecast data studio dashboard,
you will see data projections
over the next 14 days
for the United States.
The forecasts are
generated roughly every day
and are available for all
US states and counties.
This dashboard shows
historical data side
by side with these forecasts.
The map view allows you to
see which states are expected
to have the highest increase
in the number of deaths
and confirmed cases.
You can also quickly
navigate between states
to view the forecast
for each one.
Let's pick Arizona.
Additional metrics such
as hospitalizations, ICU,
and ventilator forecasts
are also available.
For US counties, historical
and forecast data
is available for cases,
deaths, and hospitalizations.
You can use the dropdown menu
to select one or more counties
and view a time series
visualization for that county.
Let's pick Yuma.
Additional data at the
county and state level
is available in the
BigQuery table and CSVs.
In addition to our partnership
with the Harvard Global Health
Institute, we work
closely with SADA
and HCA Healthcare care to make
the COVID-19 public forecasts
available in the
national response portal,
with the goal of ensuring as
many people can have access
to the data as possible.
Many organizations have found
value from these types of data,
including HCA, as highlighted
here by Dr. Edmond Jackson.
Our hope is that other
organizations will also
be able to take this data and
use it to plan accordingly
to address COVID-19 needs
at the hospital level.
Let's change gears now to focus
on Google Cloud's health care
specific products
and how they're
being used to help with
the COVID-19 crisis.
We just talked about
how organizations
like HCA Healthcare are
benefiting from AI/ML
from COVID forecasting.
Data is what powers
these ML models.
However, the data plumbing
required in health care
to build those models is
challenging and time consuming.
The Google Cloud health
care API is designed
to make the data plumbing
easier, cheaper, and faster
to accelerate health data
interoperability and enable you
to unlock the power of your
data to create and/or consume
AI models, to run large-scale
cross-modality analytics,
and to build and deploy
novel health applications.
Let's continue with
the COVID theme
and walk through an example of
how a large provider system was
able to quickly gain insights
into COVID admissions using
the health care API.
When COVID hit, it
exposed a real problem
in many provider systems.
The disease was moving
faster than the data
that they were using to
make their decisions.
Some of the
challenges they faced
included data latency, where
their existing data analytics
ran off Epic Clarity
exports, which can often
be more than 24 hours old.
Data continuity-- regional
hospitals and clinics each
had their own siloed view
of just their own data.
And finally,
available IT skills--
a real lack of
local IT staff made
rollout of a new technical
solution impossible.
What they needed was a way
to tap into real-time events,
and in particular those that are
broadcast on the HL7v2 message
stream.
The solution that they
developed leverage the real time
feed by consuming the
HL7v2 message feed directly
into the health care API,
transforming that data
into FHIR, and then
projecting that data
into BigQuery for analytics.
The data feeds
were then combined
across regional
hospitals and clinics
to create a single aggregated
data set for the entire system.
They were then able to use
pre-built Looker dashboards
that combine national data
with their local data,
as well as their own data,
to gain better insights.
Let's dive a bit deeper into
the specifics of the solution.
The Google Cloud
health care API was
the key to moving from sometime
to real-time analytics.
We were able to plug into the
Rhapsody interface engine,
and land the HL7 messages
directly into the health care
API message store.
We then leveraged our
data harmonization suite
to transform the HL7v2 messages
into a FHIR representation
in real time.
The health care API FHIR
store can automatically
project the data
through to BigQuery
and can be visualized
using a Looker dashboard.
Traditionally,
standing up this kind
of a solution within the health
care system would take months,
but we needed to act
at the speed of COVID.
And by using the health care
API, we were able to do this.
The result was that the
C-suite had visibility
into real-time data about the
number of cases, resources,
and utilization.
And all of this was
delivered from start
to finish in just three weeks.
Before we move on, I want to
take a slightly closer look
at the architecture
behind the solution.
The first step in
delivering the solution
was setting up the
cloud environment
using the data
protection toolkit, which
automates the deployment of
cloud projects and resources
following HIPAA best practices,
automating permissions
using the principle
of least privilege,
and setting up log retention.
Once patients are admitted,
transferred, or discharged,
the EHR, or the
electronic health record,
sends out an HL7 message, which
our Pub/Sub adapter listens
for, captures, and delivers
to the health care API HL7v2
message store.
The HL7v2 data was
converted to FHIR
via transformation pipeline
run in Cloud Data Fusion.
However, that wasn't
the only source
of data brought
into the solution.
We also brought in data
from operational systems
in CSV format.
We worked with the system to
create a Whistle Mapping config
to harmonize the data into FHIR
from these different sources,
which were in different schemas,
terminologies, and value sets.
As a result, both
operational and clinical data
are harmonized in real time
to the FHIR store, which
then streams data directly into
BigQuery so that the Looker
dashboards reflect up
to date information
for decision-making.
As we discussed on
the previous slide,
there's a lot of value in
the structured data contained
in the HL7 messages and
the operational data.
However, there is a
significant amount
of value locked up in
unstructured data contained
in the clinical narrative
of the progress notes.
Extracting this value
requires a different approach.
Let's dive a little bit
deeper into clinical entity
extraction.
What you're seeing
here is a small part
of a typical ICU note.
It's very dense.
There are lots of
unintuitive abbreviations.
There's weird punctuation,
because large sections
are often generated by the EHR.
And there are two languages
here, both English and Latin.
But there is often more
detail and richness of context
buried in the clinical note.
And that is important
to understand,
and it is not available in
the structured EHR data.
So what can we do about this?
The Healthcare
Natural Language API,
which is coming
soon in beta, will
help you find, assess, and link
the knowledge in your data.
In particular, it allows you
to extract clinically relevant
entities from a
text to understand
the relationship
between those entities
to understand the context in
which those entities appear
in the text, as
well as to associate
those with known ontologies.
In addition to the capabilities
offered by the Healthcare
Natural Language API, the
need for custom information
extraction models that have
high fidelity for health care
and life sciences
applications is significant.
AutoML entity extraction
for health care,
which is also coming
soon, provides you
with the ability to
generate high quality custom
models for health applications
with no coding skills required.
Just upload and label
the training data,
train the model with
the simple click,
and then deploy
that model at scale.
A major US health center
was seeing patients
presenting to them with a wide
variety of different symptoms
through multiple clinical entry
points, including their call
centers, chatbots, telemedicine
visits, and of course
in-person care.
The data that was
being collected
at the different entry points
was not connected together,
and there was not an easy way
to pull all this data together
to identify common patterns
in their population.
In response, they
decided to kick off
a pilot to automate
the extraction
of clinical information from
these unstructured data sources
to better make more accurate
predictions and better
triage their COVID-19 patients.
The early results of this
effort were promising.
They pooled all the
disparate data sets together
into a single store and
also enhanced their chatbots
to ask COVID-19 specific
questions as well.
As a result of their ability
to better extract information
from multiple
sources, they've seen
many improvements in the
accuracy of their diagnoses,
as well as a reduction
in their time to treat.
They're also exploring how
this can be used in the future
to better identify chronic
conditions related to COVID.
To close, I want to
highlight one of our partners
that's working on finding
new treatments for COVID-19.
Schrodinger is one
of those partners.
Schrodinger is a drug and
material discovery company
that has built a platform that
uses physics and chemistry
principles to create
computational models that
predict how different
substances will interact
at the molecular level.
These simulations can be
run at an enormous scale
to assess billions of
molecules in silico
before selecting candidates
to take into the lab.
We announced our initial
partnership in May
when Google Cloud was providing
Schrodinger with access
to powerful computing capacity
to accelerate drug discovery
for its commercial partners
and its own internal pipeline.
However, more recently, and
in response to the COVID-19
pandemic, Google Cloud
is providing Schrodinger
with 16 million
hours of GPU time
through our researcher
credit program.
And this is to enable
computational drug discovery
for COVID-19, which
if used consecutively,
would equate to 1,826 years
of around the clock computing.
To accelerate this
drug discovery process,
Schrodinger has teamed up
with Takeda, Novartis, Gilead
Sciences, and WuXi AppTech
in a philanthropic initiative
to share ideas,
resources, and data,
with the goal of developing
novel and viral therapeutics
for COVID-19.
We're very excited to be able
to support this initiative
and we wish them the
very best of luck.
We hope that you've found
this useful and informative
and that this will be
helpful for your organization
as you combat the
COVID-19 crisis.
We're now in the
final month of Next.
We have several Healthcare
and Life Science sessions
that you might find useful.
You can easily find
this information link
from the Google Cloud Healthcare
and Life Sciences website,
or from our Next home page.
Thank you very much.